hi welcome to
our panel discussion where we're going
to be talking about some of the recent
trends
in screening g-protein-coupled receptors
gpcrs
and i really am excited about the people
that are going to be speaking on this
panel
we make this a really engaging
um and informative time over the next
hour i'm going to start with just some
introductions i'm going to leave
let each of the panelists actually
introduce themselves
i'm the moderator i'm annette gilchrist
i'm an associate professor
at midwestern university which is just
outside chicago where
currently it is freezing cold
i uh have a second company
um that i recently started called my
genome rx which has to do with
pharmacogenomics
and i worked in the field of gprs for
a couple decades um i did a postdoc
with heidi hamm and together we started
a company based on the interactions
between
g protein coupled receptors and g
proteins and so
i have for many years studied
that receptor g-protein interaction
and how that really shapes how the cell
signal and how you can screen for them
i'm a big fan of functional selectivity
and alistair's modulators which i think
we'll touch on today
and so i'm really happy that i have the
opportunity to introduce
some of the panelists that are going to
be talking today so i'm actually going
to
ask kevin to start and introduce
yourself and
uh tell us a little bit about your life
in the world of gpc arts
thanks very much annette it's wonderful
to be here and
and welcome everybody um i'm kevin
flager i'm a professor at the university
of western australia and harry perkins
institute of medical research
i'm head of molecular endocrinology and
pharmacology there and have been for for
many years now
and i'm also director biomedical
innovation so i have a broader portfolio
of responsibility there as well and i'm
also um
chief scientific advisor of dimerics
limited which is a spin-out company
which is
looking particularly at receptor
complexes and heteros
and trying to understand the normal
pharmacology of those
um juan how about you next
thank you and that so my name is juan
jose fong
i am currently principal scientist at
gpcr therapeutics
uh a drug discovery company focused on
targeting jupiter heteros
in cancer um the company headquarters is
in
seoul korea but we have a small group
here in the san francisco bay area
i received my academic training in uh
the lab of dr brian kabilka at stanford
university
studying gpcr dimers and structural
dynamics
i've spent significant time in industry
studying membrane proteins
and performing assay development and
high-speed screening
and currently i am focused on assay
development and new technologies to
bridge the gap
between in vitro and in vivo gpr
heteroamer pharmacology
what do you mean hi everyone i'm yamil
never sheesh i am
a little bit i have a little bit
different background or at least
a different occupation right now i'm of
the founder of dr gpcr
which is an ecosystem designed to bring
together stakeholders
interested in understanding gpcr's
depressing coupled receptors
which as we all know control virtually
everything in the body
and the mission of dr gpcr is to bring
us all together
all of us who love gpcrs whether we're
interested in dimers heterodimers
homodimers
or even as functional selectivity so
that we can work together
to better understand and better target
the receptors
and within the context of dr gpcr i have
created different programs
one of them and thank you annette for
for inviting me is the dr gpc podcast
and i've had
two of you here on the podcast kevin and
annette
and the idea is to promote and talk
about all these wonderful scientists who
spend
decades of their life working on dpcrs
outside of dr gpcr i have my training
in biochemistry but i've worked in the
field for about 20 years
uh interes i've worked um in on
chemokine receptors and i've used
different biophysical methods to better
understand structure function
relationships of chemokine receptors
including functional selectivity and i'm
really excited to be here today
thank you arie
oh hi my name is arthur kovacker
i work in astrazeneca boston
um and unlike you all
um i'm trained as organic chemist and as
a profession i move a few years before
to chemical biology group in
um astrologer so i started as a
medicinal chemist i work on different uh
small molecules
and then when in ashranica we open
chemical biology group i moved there
and i'm part of target deconvolution and
target engagement
team so my main focus is working on
small molecule target decomposition and
target engagement
and i support multiple drug discovery
projects
at different stages from it
identification to lead optimization
even the clinical candidate selection so
unlike you all i won't say that i'm
expert in gpcs
but i work on many different type of
proteins depends
on the soluble protein then membrane
protein single pass multipliers
and then i have work on even gpcr
proteins
and recently we have published a
paper on cellular thermal shift as a
septa
which can be used as one of the
screening method for gpc or something
thank you talk about that later that
paper that was great
aj do you mind sure absolutely thank you
first of all for um having me over
and hello everybody it's really nice to
kind of be with all of you today
um yeah so i'm ajala i'm
co-founder and chief scientific officer
of blue therapeutics
uh you know we are a platform company uh
built around receptor interactive mix so
we target
gpcr head trimmers non-gpcr ones so
there's so many receptors that dimerize
for functionality and so we target all
of them and our core
areas are in cns and oncology but we're
also expanding into
uh you know uh infectious disease and so
on
my my academic background is a little
bit varied as well so i was in a medical
chemistry background initially with phil
portages at the university of minnesota
we were targeting making ligands for
opioid
you know mlr5 canada all kinds of
receptor heteros
then i moved on to harvard where i was
with clifford wolf
we worked on nerve regeneration spinal
cord injury
and also neurobiology of pain before
starting the company so yeah i'm super
excited we can talk about dimers gpcrs
whatever have you
exciting well i'm actually excited to
talk about dimers and um let's start
there
or heteromers as the case may be right
kevin you'll correct me i'm sure
um so you know it's kind of funny
because
i mean it really was only 10 years ago i
think that i sat in a meeting
and listened to a debate about whether
dimers were in fact real or not it's
really not been that long ago
um certainly within my career in gpcrs
the
argument about whether um dimers
actually
form and if they're physiologically
relevant
um but i really think that's pretty much
been put
to bed i but i think we still wonder
about how do you target them
um why do they form what uh
differences are there you know like did
the drugs that we already have
buying to the dimers or not um
and and so maybe you guys can talk about
this a bit
in terms of like when you target a
receptor do you think about
does it form a dimer does it matter that
it forms a dimer
do you wonder you know what it forms the
dimer with and whether it matters
yeah it's great questions and i i've uh
again been been through the field for
for many years and and experienced that
that change
i think um it's incredibly important to
think about
complexes of proteins and and how if you
think of a gpcr sitting in a membrane
it's not like to be sitting there on its
own in fact it won't be it needs to
signal it needs to interact with other
proteins and
and the complex it forms will determine
its pharmacology
we have different allosteric modulations
happening between proteins
and if those interactions affect
the conformation and affect the ability
of the ligand to bind
to interact with its signaling molecules
and downstream effectors
it will change the pharmacology so
understanding the importance of that
is critical the question is
where does that occur when um
in the in which sailor context and
really understanding
the the relevance of the pharmacology
and that's
really why um these amazing technologies
have developed
over the years um particularly
bioluminescence forensic transfer that
um
i'm sure we're all very familiar with
now and i do a lot of work on
as does shibuya and others around the
world
looking at how these hetchma complexes
form
and really trying to understand the
relevance of them in real time in live
cells
and and then hopefully more into
physiological relevant issues
absolutely and kevin if i could play off
of what you said a little bit
i always found it really funny that the
gpcr world was so skeptical initially
about the formation of heterogeneous
especially when the term
gpcr is g-protein-coupled receptors
we're already talking about about a
heteromeric
complex we're not absolutely something
that is just by itself
so i always found it a little bit like
tongue-in-cheek and uh you know funny
uh to add to that you know i think you
asked a very important question
uh which is do you think about gpcr
heteros or
homomers or any other type of all of
them are really when you're designing
uh molecules i would actually go the
other way and we
published you know almost now 10 years
ago that morphine
quintessentially thought to be a new
opioid you know ligand
actually activates new delta
heterogeneous much better at
greater potency greater affinity so
uh our understanding of even molecules
that are currently
out there is actually flawed because we
are not looking at heteros as valid
targets so
fundamentally we get side effects we get
all these kind of things and we wonder
why we get it
uh in fact our philosophy at blue has
has literally been we get spatial
resolution and temporal resolution when
we target receptor interactions
because these receptors are interacting
as kevin said they're not sitting by
themselves
and those interactions have meaning and
we are looking for where those
interactions are happening and is that
then meaningful therapeutically
then that is something that we can
exploit but at the at the
outset chemistry has to accept that
and and look for it and if you actually
screen for
any uh you know interaction whether it's
the dopamine one opioid one
you start seeing very interesting things
happen even with the molecules that are
already out there
so uh and that can also explain the
effect side of it profile actually so i
think it's a very important
consideration to have
in my opinion
absolutely absolutely so one see
i know that you said you did dimers as
well right so
yeah yeah absolutely so those are great
points uh made both by kevin and aj
and i think um uh originally um
with our um uh company at gps
therapeutics i think uh
this we started observing uh synergistic
effects
uh upon activating uh one of the
protomers of
a set of heteromer pair and so that
really
you know evolved into investigating
those types of
interactions looking at synergistic
effects
between several agonist molecules and
the effect of uh inhibiting one protomer
versus the other and developing that
sort of data set
really is um a nice functional readout
of what i think a lot of us
believe believed uh what's happening but
um
it's really you know difficult to get
down to the
you know to to to proving the exact
uh designerization for example but
seeing
synergistic effects from a functional
assay that
are very uh very much different
than the signaling event from a single
protomer
is really convincing very compelling
data so
those are the types of uh experiments
that you know we
that really we're trying to uh
develop and understand um and hopefully
you know
uh uh uh help advance the
the um the the hypothesis of uh
heteromerization
and like was mentioned previously i
think you can add the layer of
complexity then of
uh where does this occur what cell type
what organ
and you can start seeing the um the wide
array of
uh uh signaling that gpcrs can possess
whether it's
monomeric dimeric oligomeric
what partner that is and so on and so
forth and i think
um it's just a sort of a fascinating
uh field to be in
so i guess absolutely can i pick up on
that
sorry i mean i think a a very good point
there
you made was that um it's about changing
the pharmacology
and and we're not just interested in in
two proteins
being close to each other or or even
interacting
it's about how do they change each
other's pharmacology and i think that's
um
very critical and um and really
is core to the definition of what a
hetero is is that changing in the
biochemical fingerprint
absolutely to put that
uh quote you said about a complex um
it forms determines the pharmacology
that's going on my next t-shirt
you know so
um but my question is when you start the
screen though right i need to screen a
new reception
i don't think about whether it forms a
dimer and what it forms a dimer with i
just think about
how am i going to screen it if i'm
looking for a new light right i mean i
work on ffa too right i'm going to do a
calcium essay i don't think about what
other
receptors might be altering
the pharmacology even though they vary
they very well may be
i just think about you know like
identifying an agonist
is there a better way to look at the
actual question in the screen should i
think first about
who's it interacting with do i need do i
need to worry about that even before i
start
uh i mean i i can kick off if uh you
know and then i'm sure kevin and juan
have a lot of thoughts here too
but fundamentally uh i i also completely
agree with kevin and juan that
these are these complexes are actually
functional units by themselves
we've seen some fascinating things the
points is if you put an opioid receptor
which is gi coupled
with let's say m-glu r5 which is gq
coupled
you can actually get gq activation by
using an opioid agonist
so there's a lot of trans activation
transient activation allosteric effects
there's a lot going on
and i know sometimes that complexity and
we're calling them complexes so the
complexity is natural
but that can be daunting but the flip
side is
understanding that and understanding on
top of
the distributed distribution that could
give you therapeutic advantage
suddenly makes going after that target
that much more meaningful so in ways of
screening then there are various
chemical strategies you can do fragment
based design you can do bi-valent
ligands there's all kinds of strategies
you can employ
but at the core of it what is a good
target
and understanding that these are
functional units by themselves it's not
some
additive thing that is happening you
know you're getting a little bit of this
a little bit of that no this is a
completely different receptor
many of them actually are constitutively
secreted from the er itself
so there's a lot going on and it is
complex it's obviou
obviously difficult and not easy stuff
but the flip side is the reward is that
much more
now you know and i just want to
illustrate this a little bit so i think
the audience can
appreciate this you can make astron
selective and mu opioid ligand as you
want
a lot of different strategies people you
know use
but the problem is in the spinal cord
and the hypothalamus you will get
analgesia fabulous
but it's also the opioid receptor is
also in the prebodzinger complex in the
brainstem you'll get respiratory
depression
it is there in the opioderic neurons
that are going to project into the
limbic system you're going to get
addictive side effects
so understanding therefore the
interactions
and going after maybe certain tissue
areas where those interactions are
happening
and maybe not happening in other areas
suddenly gives you
an entire new way to look at the
landscape
it's like looking at a map in 1d versus
suddenly 2d
and maybe 3d and everything changes and
that is the definition that
i think we can add when we think about
trimmers
and if i can add to that i think um
if i i'd like to take a little step back
i think in the beginning when we started
screening and looking for different
ligands we were just happy to get
some response and that you you referred
to getting you know doing a calcium
assay and getting
results and you would most likely do it
at the first time in in hex cells
and you obviously have other gpcrs
expressed in hex cells but i think the
tools we had back in the day
did not allow us to investigate what
other complexes would these receptors
would form
with endogenous exogenously expressed
gpcrs
or even overexpression was always a
topic a favorite topic of reviewers
especially when you were trying to
publish your work and
people were saying well you're
expressing so you might be forming
homodimers as well
but i think with the development of
technologies like bioluminescence
resonance energy transfer
or other techniques where you can very
nicely
monitor in a time dependent and
concentration dependent fashion
what happens within the cell it allowed
us to
take a step back and be able to look at
specific
heterodimers or homodimers or complexes
in the presence of specific ligands
and i love the idea of you know
selectively choosing
a ligand or a pair of ligands uh
in the context of a specific tissue to
get a specific response that's very
important on the other hand i think the
time that the ligand spends
with that dimer of interest is also
something to consider
which which could be a really
interesting way of looking at it so you
might have the same dimer in different
tissues
but depending on how long or the sorry
the same receptor in different tissues
forming heterodimers with different
gpcrs
and then the time where that same ligand
sits on both of those complexes
would provide the therapeutic effect but
at the same time potentially the uh the
side effects to the uh to the
to that compound that you're looking at
i think time is also of the essence in
there
and i just my camera is frozen that's my
apologies
and i think that that picks up an
important point about the the
technologies you mentioned i mean uh
real-time
uh assays are so important in this
because i think a lot of what we see in
terms of bias and
uh functional selectivity which i'm sure
you'll talk to in a moment um
that really a lot of that is kinetics
and an understanding
in real time so we
we probably will do high structure
screening with endpoint assays
but when with profiling and following up
those those screens
looking at real-time assets is so
important
so i'm actually going to ask ardy a
question and it's because i think that
it
is the other side of this in that often
when i'm screening i'm screening
for agonists using biochemical assays
but a lot of
screens are now phenotypic assays where
you identified something then you have
to go back the other way and say what
does it actually target
right and so how do you do that
you know like what methods do you use
when you have to go backwards
okay um so um when it comes to um
soluble proteins and when it comes to
membrane proteins it's completely
different
but when we know it's a multi-pass
transmembrane protein
in our group we mainly use two
label-free technologies
uh which is called one is called stretch
our cellular thermal shift assay and
other one is called in cell
chemoproteomics
photocrosslinking pull down essay um
and the idea behind is that many times
these multiple transmembrane proteins
they are very hard to uh purify
and then as kevin said we always want to
see what actually happening in the
biological relevance rail line
so in that case um these methods we can
use
as a taxi so we actually use this
biological relevant
assisting for cesar and in cell
chemoproteomics experiment
and usually these biochemical or
cellular reported access
are very robust and throughput but they
this assay do not prove the target
engagement under this
this is 11 setting so uh the sets are
and insulting proteomics that can bridge
the translational gap between screening
models
and this is system which is
more biological relevant system and
i can start with cesar so sexa is a
pioneer
by palago biosciences and the way it
works that
um every protein has its fixed melting
point
but when it binds to any ligand the
melting point of this
protein changes and that we can use to
find
out how the target engagement of that
protein works
and we have a paper published in acs two
years before
and there we use uh many multipass
transmembrane proteins
uh including gpcr part 2 example
and there we showed that for agonies
antagonists and even alerts allosteric
binding
ligand of part 2 we could use tetra very
well
and then the other method which i was
talking was insulting
proteomics photographs linking and that
network little
uh different than this um schedule
method
so here uh we we know the region
and um we know the acr around that
molecules
and we can use to uh form
affinity probe and again this
uh if you know um
um from scripps left crawfish paper so
he used this technology he pioneered
this technology
so the way it was that we make this
photo finity pro
and then we uh this photofinity probe
it forms covalent bonds with the probe
and then protein
and everything is into the relevant
biological system so like a cellular
system
uh any disease relevant system and then
we can click
with biotin and then do the streptavidin
pull down experiments
and this is again the label tree
technique
here we have to of course the modified
the drug molecule but again this is the
label free technique and we have
the tremendous success finding the
actual the uh target
of uh being case from the phenotypic
screening of those
gpcr ligands by these
yeah i'm a techniques fan of phenotypic
assays i don't do them but i think
they're
phenomenal in terms of the information
that they can give you
um with the sets of those are you
are you able to do dimers as well
because i would think right a dimer is
going to have a different melting point
than a monomer
is so maybe that
i think when we do it uh it is very hard
to know it is timer
uh so sexual we can do it as a western
dot section which is the classical
cetera
and then the mass specs etc so classical
etc is if we have an antibody it becomes
the targeted approach
and if we don't have an antibody then we
do this mass specs extra which is
discovery approach
so it depends on if we can see monomer
or dimer by
this antibody or if we can see monomer
or timer by
a mass spec right
so label free anybody else doing label
free
doing essays that you don't have to
add tags to your receptors anybody else
doing that it's so interesting i just
received today
a message from dr huyadi's lab from
samuel west university from budapest and
they just published a paper in jbc
where they're using breadth so
bioluminescence resonance energy
transfer
to do label free binding assays of
ligands with gpcrs
i haven't had a chance to read it but it
sounds really exciting and they're using
the
garcia luciferase um as an energy donor
to do to actually screen for ligand
binding to gp series which could be a
really cool paper too
to take a look at yeah i mean they've
done
some threat where instead of labeling
the receptors they label like downstream
targets that are activated um
[Music]
but those are always right anytime
you're not actually labeling then
you have issues with what you have
labeled and is it a direct
um interaction or not
uh i mean i know why we do it but uh
um but but nobody's using like impedance
or
uh surface plasma spr
no no all right yeah
um i'm not either i think it sounds
great um
but i don't have the instrument in my
lab so yeah
not happening um okay so i'm gonna step
back and i'm gonna ask a question of
aj and juan and it's because you both
brought up the fact that you work
in oncology with gptr's and i have to
tell you right of all the areas
that gpr gpcrs spend a lot of time
oncology isn't one of them right so what
what brought you to oncology
in the world of gpcrs because they're
not well represented in that case
uh agent you start oh
i can't hear you
so maybe maybe go ahead there you go
ah i was muted sorry
i know juan you can go ahead first and
come after you yeah i i think um at
least for
uh you're definitely right in that i
think it's
uh what seems like a you know sort of a
new field for
for gpcrs um but i think
at least for gpcr therapeutics we
really did notice um that
uh we focus a lot on chemokine receptors
to particular
cxcr4 and we noticed you know looking
through
uh expression databases txtr4 really is
highly overexpressed in many cancer
types
exactly and so that alone is
a reason to take a look you have you
know the uh
mechanism of sdf1 as a chemo attractant
you can really see the the role of of
that
in uh really you know promoting
uh for example uh cells moving into the
tumor microenvironment for example and
really
um having the ability to avoid any uh
chemotherapy and so
um just just based on the biology of
tftr4
for gpcr therapeutics that really made
sense uh through initial screens
uh we found that um these are
uh by molecular fluorescence
complementation screens
to look at uh coupling with other
proteins
we found that it really had the
potential to heteromerize
with quite a variety of different gpcrs
and so that really turned into looking
at
you know expression of cftr4 and other
gpcrs as well
in in cancer and interesting patterns
are are observed and so that really was
the
uh the motivation for um pursuing
uh that path and we know that gpcrs are
very druggable and so the idea
to look at them in another disease
context really just
seems like a great opportunity that i
think
more and more companies and labs will
start uh researching
absolutely and and to play off of uh you
know what you're saying juan
from our focus as actually for oncology
has been
as you know we're talking about all
receptor interaction interactions so
we're targeting nuclear receptor head
terminus in fact nuclear receptors have
to heterorize many times to even
function
but in the gpcr context too like a lot
of gpcrs actually are expressed in
immune cells and
we now understand the power of immune
oncology and there are ways to
you know be believed to kind of just
explode that field
by not looking at just the glycoproteins
and a few other things that people are
mainly focused on right now but i think
using
right in that world can really kind of
expand that so
it's still pretty early stage on the
gpcr site for us but it's a
really exciting phase because i think
there's a lot to unlock there
for that's sure
emmett can i ask a quick question uh as
you
most of you have heard cxr4 is one of my
favorite gpcr's and i've worked on it
quite quite some time and one of the
issues with cxcr4 is that it only has
and which is essential for so many
physiological events
so in the context of cxr4 in
in in oncology uh you you mentioned uh
that juan that you
you realize that it's here4 is
co-expressed with other
gpcrs when when you screen and
the idea of targeting cxcr4 mediated
pathways
in in oncology what would be
how would you modulate it what kind of
molecule would would you be looking for
knowing that
right that's that's a great question i
think this gets back to
some of the initial uh topics that are
discussions that we had that
um we really do believe that the gpcr
hetero
has this novel pharmacology that's uh
underexplored and so really
i think being able to pick up
sort of those nuances a a specific novel
uh
pathway really is where we are focused
so
you have your you know agonist
antagonists and versus agonist classes
but really
i think what we're those are canonical
ligand classes
we really consider the gpsr heteromer as
being its own new
signaling entity and so therefore really
looking at um and that hinted at this
looking at phenotypic screens is really
a great way to sort of deduce what the
effect might be of this novel
pharmacology where
classical canonical gpcr pathways
may tell us you know you really don't
want to use this type of molecule
so it's it's really it's a great
question
it's uh difficult and we're really uh
you know trying to approach it from
sort of a wholesale uh or tissue
approach where the gbcr heteromer is
really going to
dictate um what that pharmacology is
um without you know having uh
an assumption as to what it is that the
ligand is going to
to do thank you that's phenomenal i
i think it's it's such a great way of of
you know
evading the question well not the
question but the the problem of having
one chemokine receptor and one ligand
that does almost everything that you can
think of in the body
i guess that that i have to ask do you
text cells i'm going to guess no
no they're useful for
many many things and you know i think we
all love working with them
but um to really answer the questions
that
that we need um getting the system as
close to
as you know disease relevant as possible
is key
so about you kevin what cell line are
you using are you oh he's excellent
i mean way to start off right and if you
just want to do a little bit of
screening a little bit understanding of
absolutely yeah so for that it works
great but i agree with
pretty much everybody else here uh we
need to understand the phenotype
uh in the context of it because by the
way the other problem that i think
someone else mentioned too already hexos
have their own endogenous receptors and
their
endogenous effects their profile which
can be so
different you go to an immune cell from
there you go to neuronal cell the
effector profile is so different too and
we now
with some of michelle dubia's work so
many other things we are understanding
how
those effectors actually modulate the
exact g-protein interaction as well so
this is complex stuff and moving away
too much from the native tissue and
native
cell types is dangerous because we can
then get very erroneous data we think
we've
solved the problem you go into native
tissue and suddenly it doesn't work at
all
yeah absolutely and then we our strategy
is to to find some normal pharmacology
in
excel and then partner with people very
rapidly who have
very good animal models um to actually
understand that the the phenotype
and then and then we actually look at
that and and
you're right i mean often we see things
happening in excel
that predicts novel pharmacology but
predicting whether that's a good thing
or a bad thing
can be difficult and often it's when you
go to a nano model and
that really gives you that
differentiator so i i completely agree i
mean a hexcel is a starting point um but
then we we definitely work up to more
feels physiologically relevant
systems as quickly as possible and so
your point about
receptors in in in hex cells i mean
people think hex cells are empty and we
put our
transfecting our receptors and that's
that's what's there but we're actually
doing some work now with crispr
and we're actually um adding bread tags
to
uh receptors that are in this in the
cell um so
including cxco4 actually so um so those
receptors are in the hexel
and we can't forget that so uh very
important
yeah same with chose right i mean on the
other end u2 os the
three lines i would say that every lab
has to have
or at least we have maybe not everyone
we have
exactly what feed is the big screens
right it reminds me like when you want
to actually do it right and you want to
let's say take even a
uh let's say mouse drg neuron or
something so we started phenotypic
screens with mouse drg
because we wanted the exact iron channel
profile
but then you get like 20 000 cells from
one mouse
so there are complications with
phenotypic screening and i think that's
why hexa sources have a place
to get you started and everything
because i can't imagine doing a
you know insulin go and post that a
hundred thousand compound screening in a
mouse drg that would be disastrous
friday
i mean i don't know if you have read and
i was talking about this
uh technology benchmark from scripps lab
so he does this phenotypic screening
using a small molecule
but using the fragments so and he call
is that fully functionalized fragment
screening
and in astrazeneca we use it we have a
lot of success
doing it and initially building that
library of
um i mean we have a library using uh
what being suggested but then we have
our own
uh database and we have our own library
and together we have almost thousand
molecules
and so far we have identified many
different um
targets using this phenotypic screening
actually rc if you don't mind me asking
a follow-up question because i think
it's relevant
how do you build a larger fragment
database because you know sometimes you
get a lot of conservation right once you
go to the fragment level
so i was just curious how you guys think
about that because i think it's very
relevant
yeah so we have a fragment um what we
call
fragment based drug discovery uh
department
so they have their own fragment library
and um
when we do this um phenotypic screening
we always do in three different doses so
10 micro mole may be 50
and 100 so sometimes 100 micro mole is
too
much but then whatever we and initially
we get some
heat for example out of those thousand
molecules we get
20 30 molecules uh as if we know to peak
heat
but then when we do the dose response
not every
not all uh pan out so whatever heat we
get
uh from finally using these those
response we do these target
deconvolution efforts using
um incentive proteomics which i was
talking about
and then so here the main uh aim of our
phenotype screening is to find the
target so not define the latent so once
we
we always want to have a new novel
target
so that's how we do actually thank you
i think it's such an interesting way to
screen right sort of backwards
right yes
it's almost um so i've always loved
pharmacogenomics because i think of it
as being
unbiased right i mean i love the
genetics part of it right when you look
at um
juan as you mentioned right that you
went back to to the
informational databases and found that
cxtr4 was just
upregulated all the time in cancer right
that's unbiased information
and i think sometimes when you use a
phenotypic assay and you go backwards
and look for the ligand it's very
unbiased i don't have a target that i
love that i need to find
a ligand for i go at it by i have
something a problem i need to solve in
essence that
you know whatever solves this pulses um
but the the problem has often been when
you go backwards that you
identify potentially a target that
you're really not interested in
right i mean
that you don't really want to turn off
maybe or or alter i don't know
um at least i would think that that
would be occasionally a problem um
all right so i do want to i want to ask
a quick question
about structures we have to talk about
structures right we're in the we're
working on gptr's
the evolution of um
crystal structures in the world of
gpccrs has
certainly changed over the last 10 years
i mean um
while we don't have an uh image for
everything right i don't have a crystal
for every gpcr i've certainly got a lot
more than i had
um do you use that information when
you're screening do you
use any kind of rational drug design
in your approach when you're thinking
about
targeting a receptor um i'll start with
one
yeah so like you mentioned you know the
the
advancements in the field are just
amazing it seems like
you know every month there's new
structure or several coming out so it's
just
a lot of fantastic work and i think
um if it if it isn't already i think
most
gpcr drug discovery programs will be
um utilizing that information one way or
another
whether it's through virtual high
throughput screening
if your target's available i think it's
a phenomenal way to
really you know cut down on on uh
potential you know not non-hits and
really save
resources on the wet lab side so
i think it's really all that information
is super valuable
um being a head rumor uh a specific
company we really
um would you know like to see the the
the head armor uh crystal structure
which i think is still
um there's definitely dimer structures
uh tr4 itself
uh was solved as a dimer so um
understanding
the structural information of a
heteromer would be
uh extremely valuable for for a company
that's focused on dimers
um but i don't think the the field is
there just yet
um i think there's complexities in um
isolating the you know for example a
headroom repair
so i i think for um in the general gpcr
drug discovery field
using structural information i think is
gonna it's going to become
common practice if if it isn't already
um uh i i see it in the near future as
really being
part of a foundational type of program
for
for any any company
yeah i can i can tag on to that you know
completely agree with that assessment
and
i still remember in 2007 when the global
collab published the adrenergic receptor
crystal and it was suddenly like wow
like this is actually possible and it's
not all just based on rhodopsin
and you know in the hetrumer context too
there is
good sense now of the conservation of
interfaces where
hypermerization is happening or
autoimmunization just to be
fair and i think that is also
very important right because many times
we think about
you know oh they're just two things
they're they're stuck together
but then the orientation of how they are
stuck together matters a lot
uh and how you can then bridge that what
are is the allosteric site on the other
side available
and so many design factors um so we take
all that into consideration there's
you know the in silicon portion can cut
down and i think juan talked about this
too like you
you can spend a year you know trying to
figure out how to work with it
and if you have good structures but
fortunately we do we don't have a head
trimmer structure but at least we
understand the
interfaces where tetramerization happens
so that
it's already helping us immensely we
couldn't have done this probably
15 years ago to be honest it's it's so
much harder
absolutely so kevin does it change the
way that you screen
at all um not necessarily the way we
screen but certainly
um thinking about interfaces we're
starting
to see a lot of really interesting
trans activation has been has been
mentioned before um not necessarily just
between gpcrs actually but
but between other receptors and pcrs and
kinases absolutely and
and other receptor molecules
so it's it's interesting to understand
those interfaces because i think those
become a really interesting
um therapeutic target um and
we're always looking for new targets um
and
uh and actually i think there's there's
still an awful lot of
target discovery uh out there where
we're actually looking at a hedgerow
complex as a novel target
well because i'll just follow up on that
right because the advantage often times
by having a target
of a protein that's associated with the
gpcr
is that it may provide you with tissue
specificity for example right i mean
isn't
it really good that you have a means by
which to make it a more targeted
drug definitely definitely and i think
that's one of the great selling points
of these complexes
is the the tissue specificity and that's
been seen
um on number of occasions um and i think
the targeting of that and therefore
reducing the side effects
um and that's that's where a lot of this
is is being driven from
is the the reduction of the side effect
profile
so so we have to come back to it because
of course i love functional selectivity
right i'm all about the g
proteins um do you really i mean
when i originally um
thought uh compounds that could
induce um coupling between a receptor
and a given g protein i mean there
really wasn't even language for it back
then we made it all up as we went
um but i think now it's clear right i
mean you have receptors that couple to
more than one g protein that couple to
erupt
in that you can really determine sort of
the downstream effectors
uh based on your ligand that you start
with right i mean
you have acceptors that just the
endogenous ligands for the chemokine
receptors
have a multitude of g proteins that get
activated downstream depending on which
ligand you give them so
so i think do you think of that as being
an issue
though when you think of like
decompolation i mean
it's hard enough when you just think of
one simple
receptor one g protein
interaction that you're having to
identify what happens when you have to
figure it out among
you know such a broad array
i think one of the challenges is
understanding which which
particular signaling pathway has the
therapeutic
effect so i think um
functional selectivity is it's an
amazing i mean it's like
it's like heterogeneization it opens a
pandora's box
and it becomes incredibly complicated
incredibly quickly
and drilling down to which pathways are
really
causing the effect i mean for example in
the in the vague depressing system
i mean it generally looks like it's all
about one g
protein so i mean there might be other
depot interactions but
as far as we see it's about the one
g-protein pathway so
um so what what the convolution i think
is that is the key to this and
and um and coming back to the hexane
three cell if it happens in html3 cell
does it happen
in the the the body where in the target
uh organ so um so that that's the
challenge i think is the decompolation
and if i could just kind of add a point
to that and this is something that i
wonder and maybe
someone here knows the answer um is
there also such a binary aspect to it
can a ligand for instance be
just biased towards one uh
you know one effector could there be for
instance temporal nature to it for
instance it could be
g protein activated in certain contexts
it could be
beta resting it could be some other
factor
and and could that be happening even in
the same tissue but based on different
temporal
or other contexts to see state context
so
these are some of the questions that
like bottles the mind for me i don't
know if any one of you has
any knowledge and that i would love to
hear about it well they know that
right for like beta 2 as beta 2 becomes
adonergic receptors you become more
phosphorylated you switch
from gs to gi right so it's a
phosphorylation mechanism
um and there's all kinds of papers about
the the bar
code in absence of the gpr right and
um it helps identify
uh what g proteins are going to interact
or what a rustin is going to interact
with the receptor based on the
phosphorylation status of the receptor
um
i think a lot of ligands activate more
than one
g code more than one g protein and in
fact both the g protein and the eruption
i mean
um but i think
i i think right what we want is
something like can you make it selective
right i mean can you make it just gi
couples or just
gs couples and and and
ignore all the other um stuff
that that would otherwise be activated
i'll i'll tell you we've recently we we
did a screen
um on a receptor and we thought what we
wanted was
g2 coupling but it turned out as long as
we turned off
the beta arresting we would push enough
down the gq we were fine so we could
look for just
antagonists of beta-arrestin
or agonists of the g2 coupling you know
you didn't have to pick
agonists with g2 you just turn off the
other and you're okay
so um you know i think when you think of
functional selectivity it may just be
you sort of need to fine-tune
you know which g-protein you're you're
turning on downstream
but but to your point i don't think we
always know
right i mean um
be willing to bet the vast majority of
receptors they have no idea what
coupling to g12 or g13 does to them
um we talk about gi but what about geo
and gz
you know with the g proteins that are
harder to turn off and turn on
selectively it becomes harder to know
physiologically what's the relevance
in itself right you mentioned cancer
right i mean
a lot of immune cells right they have
g16 they don't even have
um as much q11 and 14 right they've
pushed to a different pathway
so it doesn't matter um and and for me
i actually think about things like what
about age what about the age of the
cells does it matter because your
pattern probably changes
right as you age in your cells for what
g
protein you express um
so so i'm gonna have um one
more question and it's because i can't
not
talk about it even though it wasn't on
my list of questions um
somebody mentioned nuclear receptors and
of course that immediately made me think
of
um do you look at where your receptor is
in the cell the ellipsis is
intracellular
does it matter do you care
when you're looking at your gpcr because
it's it's a hot topic right now right in
terms of
receptors that are not necessarily at
the plasma
membrane surface so do you look
we certainly do i mean we've we've spent
a lot of time recently looking at
um in sailor trafficking and
and developing um markers to look at
where
where in the cell the bread is happening
and following that in real time
you're doing it with the bread you're
like looking at the location based on
the
yeah three breaths proteins okay yeah
absolutely so so using the red proteins
um
so this is this is um um leveraging the
work from nevin lambert
and and using a system where there were
proteins in different compartments and
and using that to follow
the receptor around around the um around
the cell
and we developed um that a little bit
further and particularly looking at
forward trafficking as well as a
as a novel um approach to look at where
that functional
um effect is coming from from the hetero
complex
that's awesome and they're inside the
cell right your receptors
yeah absolutely i mean obviously they
they internalize um and um
and then a lot of heteronization is
around the forward trafficking and how
these are chaperoning each other up to
the
to the surface so there's an awful lot
of pharmacology
and david calabarro over in birmingham
is doing some amazing work looking at
these the the intracellular domains
where
you've actually got actin cytoskeletal
um
domains versus ring fencing this
activity so
you can monitor these in with single
molecule
techniques to actually see these these
receptors
very much complementalize within these
these little
domains in the cell so i think um again
cells are not just bags of water they're
they're very complicated
things and um and yeah actually
understanding where
this is happening is i think the next
the next uh
domain of of uh of endeavor for our
field
i actually completely agree with that
but you know they
you know when we were working with
points at drg neurons
you know if you think about
physiologically the ganglion
is by the spinal cord but the nerve
endings
are peripheral if we think about what is
happening in that context it's like
something is happening in boston and the
cell body is in seattle and
you know and so how is the signaling
even
functionally you know relevant right in
that context so
we've been thinking about these things
signaling endosomes uh
you know is is there a constant level of
tone that
is maintained so these are all great
questions i don't think we are
there yet to answer a lot of these
things but i think we're plugging away
at it
understanding that i think it's
therapeutically relevant because
otherwise then we're treating the wrong
problem
in the wrong place or the right problem
in the wrong place either way
if you're in the wrong you know
yeah exactly
anybody else absolutely yeah just
uh agreeing with what's been said i
think it's something that's
you know of utmost importance and i
think there's been
enough studies to show that a lot is
going
on in different compartments within the
cell
and i think it's like aj mentioned i'm
not sure that
we're completely there yet but being
aware that
some of the effects that are being
observed could be due to
um uh and endothelmal signaling for
example
um but you know we're kind of just
scratching the surface
and you know literally the first step
make sure that your receptor
that you're trying to target from a drug
discovery standpoint is at the membrane
surface and then
going from there but really building in
all those other layers i think is
definitely a a next step
i love it i can only echo what's been
said i think it's important to know who
where and when these these things are
happening
and are these physiologically or passive
physiologically relevant in order to
specifically target these with molecules
that um you know we would screen for
okay so with that i'll have my final
question and it's
um you know not your what's your if you
were a drug what would you be questioned
but it's close
so where do you see gpccr screening
in two years like in the future what
would you love to have
kind of thing if you were
fewer harry potter and you could come up
with your own screen
for a gpcr what would it be
what problem would you solve
and i'd i'd like to see some some
structures with diamond faces and
and that was picked up earlier so that's
what i'd like to see
yeah i think uh dimer
uh maybe you know cryo-em complexes with
uh signaling uh partners whether it's
beta-arrestin or g-protein or maybe
multiple g-proteins
um that would be fascinating
yeah i i you know to tag on to that
structure is i think the
very key area secondarily to answer i
think the microscopy world too like can
we can we get better resolution can we
find ways to actually get native tissue
you know determination for heteros right
now we use pla there's very few
techniques that are out there
if there's any development on that that
would be fantastic
and i think i'm gonna take it a little
bit out of space here
what i'd love to see is have is have
uh bioinformatic tools ai machine
learning tools
to help first of all what i would like
to see is a database where all of this
information that's available now
is compiled organized and then have the
tools to explore these questions
in a dry lab before even stepping
into a wet lab and doing any experiments
and having having that ability to kind
of i just i just rewatched
the movie the matrix and having that
ability to see
before even stepping into the lab i
think would be really
useful it would spend it would decrease
spending
when it comes to you know doing
experiments in the lab but also it would
save a lot of time
and hopefully advance the field which is
the goal for everyone
yep i agree to that i mean now with this
ai learning we have so many
um dry lab stuff we can do it so if you
can
expand on that it will be beneficial to
everybody
you know i'll tell you that mine is of
course pharmacogenomics i want to know
what all the
natural variants that people carry with
them and their gpccr's how that affects
their response to drugs and i think
there should
eventually be a database for that too
but there's not much out there now
so maybe in a couple years so
all right well i have to thank each and
every one of you
uh on the panel for joining us today and
i thank the audience for
attending thank you
thank you thank you for having us